NARRATOR: 5,000 feet up.
And for the first time ever--
It's good I got an
early start this morning.
NARRATOR: --Morgan's staring
down an Alaskan monster.
Daunting for even
a seasoned pilot,
the Great Alaska
Range is 40 miles
of treacherous ice cap peaks
and wind battered valleys.
MORGAN: Got to get a
little closer up here
and get a better
idea whether I'll
be able to fly right
over the ridges
or I'll have to fly the passes.
NARRATOR: The challenge is
choosing the safest route.
Either up and over
or down and through.
MORGAN: Mountain flying has
the potential for really strong
turbulence on even
clear, nice days,
if you get into some weather.
Like, it puts you in a
real about situation.
Route finding would
be really difficult.
So I'm trying to
manage that risk
and make the safest choice.
NARRATOR: With no firsthand
experience in the range,
Morgan's flying
into the unknown.
MORGAN: If I have
to fly the passes,
it means you have to
fly a longer route.
And as you get
closer to the ridge,
bit up against the mountains.
So it's a little more dangerous.
NARRATOR: But he
does not hesitate.
MORGAN: Now approaching the
first line of ridges here.
I'm climbing about 300 feet per
minute, doing about 83 knots.
NARRATOR: And begins his
ascent to go over the top.
MORGAN: The clouds
are high enough today
and the air feel stable.
I think I'll be able
to just fly direct.
Which is just a little
more straightforward.
NARRATOR: To clear
the highest peaks,
he's climbing to 10,000 feet.
Higher than he's
ever flown before.
MORGAN: You know, you
really see it's definitely
still winter up here.
NARRATOR: Staying
above the mountains
should be the safest route,
as long as the weather holds.
MORGAN: I believe the
air is getting cooler
here as we gain altitude.
And I'm showing a little
bit below freezing now.
Probably time to turn on
some heat in this thing.
NARRATOR: Morgan's first
trip through the range--
MORGAN: I pretty much
know right where I am.
But nice to just reference
stuff on the map.
NARRATOR: --is an opportunity
to scout the lay of the land.
MORGAN: Try to learn any
extra landmarks I can.
You never know when you're
going to be in a situation
where recognizing one
ridge or one little peak
might help you out.
You know, if something goes
wrong, chance of survivability
is pretty low.
It's a really
interesting combination
of trying to stay relaxed, calm,
but also very busy and focused.
Whoa!
A little rough up here.
Oh no.
Where the hell did
that come from?
There are definitely clouds
coming in real quick now.
That's not too good.
Can't see very far ahead.
I think I have to descend and
see what it's like in the pass.
NARRATOR: Descending into the
pass in search of clear air,
the lightweight plane
is now at the mercy
of the shifting winds.
MORGAN: It's a
pretty narrow pass,
so I need to be really aware
of any kind of potential wind
activity as I approach it.
It's pretty nerve racking being
this close to two mountains.
If I, you know,
were to encounter
a really strong downdraft
there, it could be pretty bad.
All right.
Heading up on the next ridge,
and there's still plenty to go.
Gotta remember to breathe here.
Yeah, just one ridge
away from home now.
OK.
Just crossed the last ridge and
I'm dropping down a tributary
here into our river valley.
I'm getting pumped up
for landing at our place.
But the closer I get, the more I
start to get a little low grade
adrenaline rush.
You know, our runway
is pretty short.
It's got some obstacles
on the ends, requires me
to have all my ducks in a row.
NARRATOR: Morgan
and Margaret spent
the last six months clearing
a 1,200 foot dirt runway.
But it's never been tested.
MORGAN: I'm coming in,
getting them closer.
All right.
The homestead is in sight.
I've got to be right
over these trees
so I'm not too high as
I come into the strip.
And I need to be
as slow as possible
so I get this plane to stall
and stick to the ground right
at the beginning.
All right.
Got to remember to breathe here.